[Laughter]
oh
vanessa bryant just got some new ink
with her daughter
the 38 year old mom shared the bonding
moment on instagram
posting pics and clips from the tattoo
session she and her 18 year old daughter
natalia
had with artist nico hurtado hey what's
up
the session which took seven hours
because according to vanessa
nico's a perfectionist began when he
started sketching her custom ink
miko hey what's up mamba mentality
that's right man post vanessa
yeah vanessa joked in a clip that she
was going to get mamba mentality
tattooed on her face which would be a
nod to her late husband
kobe bryant you can't tell somebody
the mentality that they should have you
just simply behave that way
vanessa shared several clips getting her
new tattoo
which was a single needle tattoo like
all of her others
before showing off the finished piece so
what'd she get
mambasita with a tiny butterfly on the
side of her arm
in honor of her late daughter gianna
bryant who died alongside kobe
and seven others in a helicopter crash
last year
gigi's mambasita nickname was a take on
her dad's nickname
black mamba our responsibility is to
always inspire
and try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned
and share those with the next generation
so that they can start
their journey with a leg up next up
natalia who opted to get
not one but two new tats
one on the side of her finger and
another on her wrist
[Laughter]
of course gigi and kobe died on january
26
2020 and leading up to the one-year
anniversary of their death
a source told et that vanessa and the
three other daughters she
shared with kobe natalia bianca and
capri
have all been extremely thankful for
their friends
and family who have helped them cope
with the tragedy back in april
etie caught up with one of vanessa's
closest friends
lala anthony who opened up about how
strong the mama 4 really is
i tell her every day she's the strongest
woman i know and um
i'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend she's
just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing